people say you know drugs you know
farmer doesn't spend that much money on
research but
to me it's like okay your brain you know
your brain doesn't use all your body's
energy right
but yeah but if you don't have your body
your brain can't work
[Music]
stephen kraftchick how are you doing oh
great great michael
wonderful to have you here how are you
good so you're talking from silicon
valley now
yes uh palo alto okay so we're right
across the street wonderful but you're
originally from actually in new york
right
yeah originally from poland but i got to
the united states when i was six so
essentially
i grew up here uh spent uh
time growing up in new york uh uh went
to school there and then
uh when college i it happened to
i ended up at the university of michigan
in ann arbor uh
and as it happened uh for nine years and
that's that's a little bit of a story
let's start let's start over there
spending nine years at university of
michigan
right so i was uh pretty early on i was
kind of fascinated by chemistry and
especially medicinal chemistry how
pharmaceuticals work and things like
that and so i wanted to study
medicinal chemistry and there aren't
that many medicinal chemistry programs
in the country
uh a really good one was at the
university of michigan
at a college of pharmacy and it actually
turned out to be
an incredible stroke of luck uh for me
to go there so
it was kind of interesting story i
applied to a
variety of schools uh michigan was kind
of ended up being my first choice i
ended up going up there
i got a work study job uh stipend and
my first week on campus there was an
undergrad i started i went to the
good office uh looked at jobs and i'd go
oh wow look a lab assistant at uh
the college of pharmacy perfect so i go
there friday afternoon
and i meet the guy there and says well
you know
it's really cleaning rat cages and you
know that job's already taken sorry
this woman who you know is doing like
cell culture biology
drug testing and cell culture uh want
you once you go meet linda
so he took me upstairs uh introduced me
to this
postdoc uh postdoc researcher linda
motring
and i'm talking about what i like to do
what i you know what i
you know what i'm interested in and she
goes well you know i mean this is like
cell culture stuff i'm not sure
you'd be really interested in that so
she said well you know let me introduce
you to
this guy over here and this was like
already like friday like 5 30
so i i go in and this is kind of the old
days you know where
this guy's in his office smoking cigars
and turned out to be the chairman of the
department of medicinal chemistry
and uh you know he said hmm
okay tell me about yourself i i go into
this real and then
says well you know we don't really have
any openings
you know we didn't have any openings but
tell me you know tell me more so we keep
on talking
and then he kind of just starts making
like he's you know he's ready to
shoot me out of office and then i go oh
by the way what about the job he goes oh
yeah you can you can start you can start
next monday
so uh you know this is just one of those
stories where just
you know i was in the right place and
you know you could say it's luck but i
kind of did my research and
i i was at the right place and you know
friday afternoon maybe wasn't at the
right time but maybe it was because it
showed that these the people that were
still there
were really passionate about their job
and they would recognize that same
passion in me
so it's not really a coincidence it's
it's you know it
i i it wasn't planned out but it you
know when i
look back of hindsight so um kind of
fast forward i started
working in the lab first like washing
dishes and of course you know
just like one of these zen books the
first thing he did he showed me this
incredibly messy lab and he said okay
why don't you watch you clean this up
and of course i was really excited and i
cleaned it up really really
great and he came back very impressed
so uh i ended up helping this graduate
student that was
struggling a little bit uh but basically
he decided okay let's let's give this
guy a helper and you know you can help
wash dishes or set up reactions and just
learn basically so basically i started i
was
very lucky to start working in a lab as
an undergrad
uh my first my my first week there
and then uh fast forward uh
four years well three years later it's
time to figure out what i'm going to do
i just did not really feel ready to go
out in the workforce i want to
get my graduate degree so i ended up
applied for the graduate program there
uh got accepted now before i was helping
a graduate student that
was a graduate student there and i
obtained my phd in medicinal chemistry
five years later why medicinal chemistry
so what was fascinating to you
looking at books and how you know sort
of the original medicinal chemistry
all the drugs came from plants you know
um morphine
uh belladonna strychnine resterpin was
the first and
uh was resterpin was the first
anti-anti-hypertensive
it was uh isolated from plan it turned
out actually
it caused depression so i was just kind
of fascinated how wow
you know things things you know cause
you know cause uh
different actions of course if you've
got some of the amphetamines which are
the original antidepressants uh they
cause high blood pressure
so you have you know kind of just very
interesting it's just just fascinating
to me just looking at the structures how
the structures
similar structures had similar
activities or sometimes similar
structures
had very different activities it was all
all fascinating so i just i wanted to
get into that
and just be you know be able to make you
know cure
cure stuff so talk to me about the
transition from
from medicinal chemistry on the east
coast now to silicon valley right so
that was another interesting thing so
actually
during my uh my grad students after i
finished my master's i always wanted to
go to california
just silicon valley even back when i was
in new york had this draw i didn't even
know what silicon valley was i thought
it was like this place i didn't realize
it was
really a construct but why what what so
so pay me the picture because you know
now it's very obvious why you know a lot
of people flock to the bay area or well
in 2020 a lot of people flock out of the
bay area but but until now a lot of
people flock in here and
why back then when it's less of a big
bubble and this like worldwide
yeah because i think especially my dad
was an electronics engineer
and then uh you know they see silicon
valley got
started in silicon silicon right
it kind of yeah but i so i kind of was
like had a hankering for getting out
here but
so kind of back the story was kind of
interesting in in uh
when i finished my masters in 1986
i said hmm you know maybe i can get out
here now so i applied to
ucsf uh the medical chemistry program
there
for the phd i got in uh
i came out here to visit when i got off
the plane the tarmac at that point sfo
we actually uh
we actually they brought up the
staircase the fresh air was just
incredible i mean this is coming out of
this is basically the trifle out of
detroit when i was in you know in ann
arbor
and that was before a mission so
california was the first to have the car
mission so
it was like night and day i go i love
this place uh
they had you know they had some they had
some a day of events for the incoming
you know potential students
right and i said oh i really want to
stay here but you know
as a grad student i'm not i couldn't
really enjoy it because you know i
didn't have much money and you may busy
in the lab
yeah you know the guy back there really
helped me out by giving me that job uh
i'll also stay so anyway ended up
staying for another
uh another three years and then right
another interesting point is that what
happened is that uh
when it was time to graduate i started
uh you know looking around for post-docs
and there was this guy i saw
a post-doc position at caltech with
peter durbin
uh very very high high-level guy in
in that field and uh i wrote up a
proposal for
antisense dna at that point i didn't
even realize it was a thing but i
figured that would be cool
because i studied nucleosides if i you
know if you string these along you could
actually
make like a code and actually
selectively block genes so i wrote up a
proposal to him
uh i i didn't get i didn't get in there
that okay whatever
so fast forward another couple of months
my boss comes back from a meeting in
california says hey you know i met this
guy and you know you might be interested
in getting a job there just you know
this company called gilead sciences
and they're doing anti-sense i go wow
great this is what i wanted to do
so as a 30 person startup at this point
in foster city
i go there uh you know and uh it's just
it's just great and uh i kind of aced
the interview
i i get the position and guess who's on
the board of the
advisors peter durbin so this is what i
kind of getting back to you always kind
of end up in the same place
and because well you just you just do
because you just naturally kind of fit
there
right well but it sounds like you know
on one hand you're saying you come back
to the same place on the other hand
a theme that i'm picking up here
throughout your experiences is that
you're very open to these opportunities
you're you're taking that that aft that
friday afternoon meeting
and you're you're getting excited about
this idea of cleaning a lab and doing it
to the best of your abilities
you're excited about accepting a job
offer in foster city with a 30 percent
start so so things are aligning but it's
not just
by chance it sounds like because you're
also advocating you're
you're actively looking for these
opportunities and harnessing them right
yeah
so i i hate to say actively looking
because i sometimes i
i'm afraid i'm a little bit more passive
but i kind of always try to place myself
in places where these opportunities are
just there and then come to me because
it's a little bit more natural if you
try to kind of you're pining for
stuff i mean some people can pull it off
uh you know the j
ventures people are just a great bunch
and they're like go-getters and they can
do it i yeah
so i compensate by just trying to be in
the right place at the right time
wonderful wonderful yeah so there i am
with peter girvin and then working side
by side with
you know a former postdoc of his so i
would have ended up there anyway
if if i had if i had gotten that post
back
i would have ended up at gilead anyway
so just
just like that it's pretty funny
wonderful and then of course uh
you know if you go go forward you know
25 years
that i i spent there uh you know it
ended up to be a fortune 100 you know a
100 billion hundred billion dollar
company wow
and almost went bankrupt a couple of
times in its early days
so you're joining a 30 person startup
with a
with somebody on the board who you who
you hope to do a postdoc with and you
end up doing similar work within the
company
fast forward 25 years and that small
startup in foster city
that somebody told you about is a 100
billion dollar company
right and then yeah so the other funny
thing is that kind of you know so
you know i during there i switched from
ended up
transitioning from medicinal chemistry
uh at the bench leading
a discovery group and then getting
drafted into the patent office
into the patent department there because
as the pharma business is all about
really patents that patented
everything and gilead's idea there was
to like
mine the patent landscapes of other
peoples and other people's patents to
figure out what what to do
and then you have to design around right
because you have some
other company has a great molecule but
you want to make something better but
they have a patent on all this broad
you know all these broad classes of
molecules you have to as a chemist
figure out okay what's going to be
active but not going to be dominated by
their patent
so i kind of spent just a just you know
two three minutes
talking about why why patents and in
pharma and med and
medicine why is it such an important
thing and and
because you know for me and and for a
lot of other people who are not coming
in from this industry
it's you know you know when we're when
we're building you know software as a
service it's it's
very hard to patent uh as far as i
understand
but but it sounds like in the field that
you were working in for many years
it's pretty it's it's a you know it's
mandatory so talk to me a little bit
about this landscape of i have ip and
patents
in medicine that's perfect so we have a
lot of clients
that do software as a service and i say
great well sometimes it's a combination
of a device that sends data
and then it gets processed server-side
so i tell them look
the device you have to file a patent on
it you have to disclose everything
that's in the device because
if it's really valuable someone's going
to open it up reverse engineer it i mean
there are outfits stuff there that
that take apart semiconductors they
slice through silicon
they do electron microscopy they they
they can figure out what your rom is by
look by looking at
looking at it and figure out what the
code they can get code out so
everything that's in the customer's
hands has to have a patent on it
server side i say yes it's great because
people can't really figure out what
you're doing so you don't need to patent
that
and you know it's tough under our patent
system to patent software and stuff but
it's good you just keep it server-side
and you're fine
with pharma though it's really you know
the idea that a certain molecule can
treat a particular disease
is it's intellectual property right
because once that information is out and
one
information wants to be free anyone in
india
anywhere africa brazil can make and go
in the lab make that molecule
right and there's nothing it's not like
you're the only you're
you're the only one that can make the
molecule and you're the only one
you can be the single source because
with today's chemical technology
uh if you give me a sample i can tell
you what it is
exactly the structured molecule usually
within within a couple hours using this
modern instrumentation we have
and then just given the chemical
knowledge recruit over to
centuries we can go in the lab and
probably make that you know within a
month we can have a pretty good
synthesis of it
so i can go to pharmacy buy a pill
analyze it send it over to contractor
basically make duplicates very very
quickly
that's why you need a patent uh if
someone has a weird machine learning
algorithm that no one
you know that's kind of adaptive uh and
it's sitting in a server
in their you know in their vault
whatever secure room
it's kind of hard it's kind of hard to
figure out how how that works although
there are some
theories that you can but besides that
the pharma it's
about that molecule right i mean and the
beauty of pharma is that you know people
complain about the patent system but
once the patent is expired you know if
the system works like it's supposed to
then anyone then that information is
free anyone can make that molecule
you know just regulatory issues but so
that's why the value i mean
we're giving them sort of this monopoly
for whatever
an average is about 12 years 11 to 12
years
it's supposed to be 20 but it's on
average it ends up because of delays
ends up be 11 12 years
and then later on the molecules are
there for anyone
so i think that's what makes the system
uh really great and that's why patenting
is very important because if you can't
you know people say you know drugs you
know farmer doesn't spend that much
money on research but
to me it's like okay your brain you know
your brain doesn't use all your body's
energy
right but yeah but if you don't have
your body your brain can't work so
to me it's like farmers and you know mo
you know
eighty percent of their budget is really
research and development because you
can't
you can't have research and development
if you don't have sales
you know uh doctors are pretty
conservative some you know people
complain about pharmaceutical
advertising but on the flip side
it takes a long time for i mean look at
the hiv drugs uh
delia developed it took a really long
time for them to really
permeate the market and they're just
like the best you know
made incredible changes in the lives of
people people suffering with hiv turning
into
a death sentence into a chronic disease
and it's still again
it took years in order for the
the medical community to really adopt
these things just talking about prep
uh which is the prophylaxis i mean that
would have been obvious
right at the start but we didn't we have
to wait like 20 years before prep became
uh became a thing so i think you know uh
pharma does get a bad rap there are some
bad pharma bros that
do give them a bad rap or overall i
think uh
you can't really say it's all that bad
you're right everything i'd love to
eventually be free all right
i'd love to spend the last few minutes
that we have talking a little bit about
your role as
what do you describe as an emotional
support angel i
i got a chance to talk to quite a few
angel investors especially here in the
silicon valley
i've yet to hear the term emotional
support angel and i just
love it so talk to me a little bit about
what what it means to you to be an
emotional support angel and you know
you're investing in general for you
both privately and in j ventures but
let's start with the emotional support
side of it
right so i said uh you know
entrepreneurs have to
think they can walk through walls so
give me i'll give you an example so
uh the ceo was raising money
uh she found a vc like a vc
slash angel type uh type or organization
uh basically told the the gp
you know what she needs and he wanted a
reference so
uh she sent she sent him my name and i
talking with him he's asking oh you know
can she be a ceo and i go yeah you know
she has this team already she
she knows what she has to delegate and
what not uh
just incredibly intense and uh
you know he says okay well let me just
you know can i just confirm you i mean
she she told me
she can raise 10 million dollars this
year i mean you know
revenue do you think that's true i just
started laughing i was like
no no way he started laughing
and he invested anyway right so
that's you know part of it and then you
know
having telling entrepreneur you know the
ceo saying well look you know
you gotta you know you you have to be
you it's good you were so intense you
were you're really positive and
optimistic you could get that
but at the same time you know you have
to kind of understand that not
everyone's
you know it is an aspirational goal so
just telling you know uh
you know maybe you know not everyone
would have that same response some
v some gps will say oh she can't okay
forget it right
but i'm just telling her yeah and then
you know the other questions
are they come back to me says oh you
know
was you know was it really doubting my
ability as a ceo and stuff and i go no
you know
he's gotta he's gotta ask these
questions uh so
just trying to calm everything down a
lot of times
these ceos they just need they just need
to talk
right right they just have that's
something that you know as a young
entrepreneur you you go
you grow up there you know reading tech
crunch and crunch right
without judgment because just when
they're talking to you they're hearing
themselves talk
right when you're when you got that you
know uh psychiatrists and now the
the mental health people and mental
wellness people talk about what's called
the default mode network it's kind of
that voice in our head that
keeps on ruminating and going in thought
loops and
doing stuff like that so when you're an
entrepreneur it's very easy to get into
that right you think oh what do they
think of me you're always
because you know you're always on
display you're always you're always
performing
you're always questioning how the
audience is receiving you so it's very
easy to get into that when you're
talking to yourself it just sounds a lot
different
than when you're saying the same thing
to someone else so just
being to being someone that they can
trust
to just to basically uh
you know listen and not be judgmental
and keep thinking confidence
i think that's important so kind of
going back you know the reason
i did tell that gp that my own opinion i
didn't think she was going to
be able to get 10 million in 2020 now it
still might happen
so i told him it might happen but
is uh just so you don't um
uh i was confident in telling him that
i don't i didn't think she could just
because i sensed that he
he he didn't believe it
so i already knew i mean if if i thought
that he
really thought she could and just was
kind of making sure
i i probably would have demurred i you
know figured out some
some way to kind of weasel out of
answering that question but a very
interesting balance
it's a very interesting balance that
you're that you're playing here on one
hand you have stake in the company and
you have stake in the success of the
company and
and part of the success is also the
company's ability and the founders
ability to continue raising the funds
yes on the other hand you are somewhat
also of a
psychiatrist and the best friend and a
mentor and an investor
right yes an emotional support angel
right so
yeah so i i pretty much knew the guy
knew you know he was convinced she
couldn't and he was just gay you know
but i think the reason he ended up did
putting in the money is because she was
so confident
so i think better way saying she was
confident that she had a shot at it
and i think that's really if you're
doing anything with startups it's all
about the shot on gold because you know
i mean all sorts of things all sorts of
things can happen you just
you don't you don't know so it's a lot
of it is it a good shot on goal
and i think a lot of vcs my
they kind of want to see free money they
want to see like money just sitting
there and pick it up oh it's an over
subscribe ground okay yeah i went in
right uh but uh so i mean
there's this other jay ventures this guy
was pitching
he claimed to have discovered uh room
temperature super conductivity
and i'm so being an ip expert i took a
look at his patents
the application he had he was about to
have an allowance
and it looked really good there were
some technical issues that even though
yes room temperature superconductivity
it was still not
clear how you're going to commercialize
it right what's the best way to
commercialize it
and you know jay ventures past just
because
they weren't you know they had to help
the guy
with this with his powerpoint but i mean
they just weren't sure if there was
going to be a big investor
coming in you know they can put in some
money he had a family office coming in
and he was good he was open to getting a
operating you know
operating guy or maybe even a cfo that
could pitch
so that that was all good that wasn't
really a problem but they just
you know is there going to be someone
you know a big investor
and well i think you're touching upon
and one thing that that you know we
didn't have time to talk too much about
that's not risk right you're you're
right risk but man i think that it
is a you know it is incredible that you
know as well
you know both as a private angel you
know an emotional support engineer but
also part of j ventures this ability to
bring in a community where
all of a sudden we have it we have an
opportunity where we have steve here who
is an expert or
is able to go and dig deep into this ip
and validate the technology i think
that's something that
you know really when you have almost 200
people that are involved with the fund
that's that's something that incredible
that can happen but steve unfortunately
we do have to we do have to end here but
i do have to ask my favorite question
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself
uh
just
the ever optimist i think that's the
ever optimist i love it i love it steve
thank you very much and and i definitely
look forward to
maintaining this relationship and and
bringing some ideas to you as well
all right thanks michael thanks for an
opportunity